thank you so much in it great this is
like one of the best problems to have
our community is getting so big that
people are meeting each other for real
and like then recognizing who each other
are we actually have too much content
for 30 minutes so we're going to move
pretty fast the first thing I'd like to
talk about is there is a JavaScript
robotics book out now this is the amazon
page for it it's available in kindle two
and most of the authors are here raise
your hand if you reach a peer for make
JavaScript robotics yeah I think nine or
ten and authors are here I need just try
to move this up a little bit but yeah so
check it out it's on amazon and it's a
great book and if you have a paper copy
um most of us will find it i think if
you walk up and ask I mean none of us
are that mean we don't bite do we no no
so one or two people asked and it was
kind of weird it was like a weird moment
I never thought that anyone would ever
ask me for an autograph for a book that
was kind of cool yeah that was
definitely that was simply a culture
shock for me too so the first thing we
talk about is the stuff that happened
yesterday so one of the questions have
got a few times is I didn't sign up for
node BOTS but I want to build what was
at the node BOTS workshop so what do I
need the main thing you need is one of
these runt Rovers kits we use the PE at
the workshop yesterday it's less than
twenty dollars for the kit you do need
an Arduino Uno to go with that Rick
can't I'll a little more about that
while I show some photos of so um I'm
super stoked that you brought that up
because after robots con I published a
five four or five part blog post series
on Bo kuz a company blog that was how to
assemble the robot that you got at
robots cough so as it turns out i plan
on doing exactly the same follow-up for
this project in the coming couple of
weeks it'll be an article on boku that
is how to build the the peewee runt
rover that you may or may not have
acquired at jsmith warsaw somebody else
had and would like to build the same
thing yourself
of parts list of course instructions
videos pictures all the above it'll be
reviewed and revised thoroughly and look
forward to that yep so how also have
some really great photos of the node
boats event and while Sarah talks a
little about what happened there Rick if
you want to get set up with your your
setup awesome then all at Sarah taken
away and then we'll go to your demo yeah
yesterday we had the second annual node
boots event here at jay's comp it was
pretty awesome we had about 60 people I
think here building boats with us and I
think every team except for one and it
gained their boats in the water sailing
around at the end of the day and the one
was because they were trying to be very
ambitious and like hack digital cameras
to include them in the boat somehow or
disposable cameras or something it was
pretty cool but very ambitious uh and uh
yeah we actually saw a couple of new
designs come out of this year's i know'd
boats we had someone build a sailboat
which was really awesome that was like a
really cool design we haven't had sell
boats before we've had motor boats and
paddle boats but this was the first
sailboat and it worked which is cool so
I'll put the Ducks I heard there were
ducks oh yeah so at the end of the day
that's the best at the end of the day we
went down to the big hotel swimming pool
and we had a race across the pool with
boats or you know just boots what you
know going around in circles when the
Wi-Fi cut out and stuff like that um and
so to get around the Wi-Fi issues a
couple of Road attendees just hardwired
the motors directly to the battery so
they could go on and forwards and and
like didn't have much other control but
that was fine and while these boats were
zooming around the pool a duck came and
landed in the pool because it wanted to
win the best new book award obviously
and so the boat or the duck was was just
kind of swimming around checking things
out and then one of these out of control
node boats just like started going
straight at the duck just full speed
ahead and the dexter swimming out of the
way it was like no
this book is getting too close for
comfort and took off and flew away but
we also had some really dedicated
attendees this year we had one team
where they went to Walmart to get like
pool noodle noodles to use to like prop
their boat up better and they actually
like got uh yeah they got a Barbie doll
and shaved her head to turn her into
like the the girl from Mad Max yeah yeah
Louie was helping with that members I
was delivering coffee to the members and
carrying items around it was all them
okay it was pretty awesome coma doofen
furiosa at the same time arioso uoy all
that movie oh that movie I want to be
imperative figure so what I grow up oh
alright so Rick you have a demo for us
sort of for a before it before I talk
about this I want to mention that Sarah
is actually the author of a chapter in
the JavaScript robotics book and her
chapter is about building a node boat so
if you want to build a node boat you
purchased the book and get instructions
directly from the experts so that's
pretty exciting also second thing a lot
of times a robotics research uses
animals in the wild as models obviously
for new types of robot designs and it
just occurred to me that if we strapped
a node boat to a node copter you would
have a duck bot that might have to be a
workshop next year duck quacks oh no no
ducks no no doc bot a team building a
boat where the way it was constructed
when it got to the side of the pool we
climb out of the pool Oh amphibious node
boats oh how did it do that like these
folks with paddles on the ends and so
the spokes would end up doubling as
wheels one thing oh my gosh amazing okay
we can do it out on that for like the
next 30 minutes
yep so this I don't know if I'll hold it
up so this is a thank you Francis that
I've been working on this for a few
months now and it was inspired by a blog
post that I saw by dr. esther kim she
had done a little demo where she was
doing video streaming from an Intel
Edison I was like that is so cool I want
to try that so I decided to do that
might notice you might actually
recognize the chassis this is like the
older sibling of the Pee Wee it's called
the Scout I believe these chassis czar
awesome it's like snapped together it
was so easy to build and drill holes
into to customize there's actually a
bunch of them up there yep it is wait
which one are we yeah oh no I'm sorry I
lied it's the whipper snapper yeah why
per se this is whippersnapper I get
scout from anyway so what makes this fun
and interesting and special to me is
that I can stream 128k 30 frames per
second over sockets to a browser and get
full like real-time video stream and to
a browser with a set of controls
actually a video that I took with my
phone at my computer of me driving this
thing around from my couch on the floor
of my apartment and crashing into my
french bulldog who seemed to not care at
all and of course this is running
entirely independently on the Intel
Edison board so the javascript is
running a node on the board so you just
plug it in and wait for it to boot up
and there it is it's a robot being
programmed by JavaScript running a node
that can also stream amazing video
beautifully over web / sockets to a
browser and it allows for this control
interface that's just buttons in a
browser that allow me to you know click
buttons like it's like a you know
command center control
ol center or whatever in my browser and
drive it around completely remotely and
it's a lot of fun oh did I mention also
that it's completely like standalone
like how incredible is that so this has
been like a passion project of mine for
past couple of months right now I'm
struggling a little bit with supplying
the right amount of power just to the
board everything else has the right
amount of power but the board i'm having
problems getting it right once i sort
that out i will be really excited and of
course publish some kind of article on
the boku blog about how to build it
yourself and i guess i'm looking forward
to when that day happens it might be a
couple maybe a couple months on from now
but but yeah it's what's super cool
about it to me is that it is all
JavaScript running on this board so it's
it's embedded JavaScript on an embedded
device so i have a bad joke for you tell
me about Reggie say this bot does
reconnaissance here's not uh I mean I'm
gonna thwart your joke yeah guess what
this robot is called what recon ball so
it's really funny that recon bought was
holding your recon vine yeah absolutely
so I I named it after Francis yeah very
significant a really funny when Francis
picked it up because it's Marie con
bought holding the Recon but the other
thing is for those of you who've never
adult with an Intel Edison what it is
it's a stamp-sized computer it's got
just hubli bluetooth all he built into
it or is it just know it's Wi-Fi it's
got Wi-Fi but let's undo it and it's
stamp-sized and it's got several
different shields that you can put it on
sparkfun has some shields that are
actually really tiny and so you can
build what looks like a smart watch out
of an Intel Edison and an OLED and we
actually oh we do have a heart care oh
yeah there you go so his the Edison is
on a larger shield you could also get
shields like this that are and this is a
full computer right there pretty great
yes because it runs linux how much do
they run okay modulo sorry he didn't
make module itself is 50 bucks and then
the shields are anywhere from like 22 42
what you get like the old LED ones like
about 40 because it got a little wet on
it I asked it seems like maybe there
should be a cheaper single chip computer
that is a fantastic Segway indoor first
hey isn't that cool segment so our first
hey isn't that cool segment is a I
actually found out about this when I
asked Twitter hey what should we talk
about it no BOTS live this is called The
Onion Omega it is a nine dollar computer
yeah yeah what exactly um it's got Wi-Fi
it's Wi-Fi enabled you can install note
on it it's it's not available yet they
are currently still making it they have
docs much that remind me a lot of like
this marks the spark I Oh she'll do have
an Arduino shield doc so if you want to
use our do we know shields with it but
yeah it's apparently nine dollars for
this little Omega onion and it's got
Wi-Fi built-in and it's amazing how the
price points are dropping on these Wi-Fi
enabled microcontrollers they're also
happy to run JavaScript this is amazing
we have one more demo well one more demo
and then a small talk so we've got a
video demo from Donovan of what is yes
this is donovan and you didn't explain
the demo because it's seriously one of
the coolest things i've i've ever seen
so about a year ago maybe it's been less
we added an animation library to Johnny
Five which allows you to instead of just
saying servo dot to to send a server to
a particular position you can script a
servo over time think it's a lot like
animating something in flash so you're
able to set a servo to go to a certain
position at a certain point in time and
you can set up as many cue points as you
want and we support easing and different
kinds of functions so that gives us the
ability to do pretty complex scripted
movements with the robot that's how this
hexapoda it's not what you're saying
here actually that's how the text apod
walks is with these scripted movements
using the animation class but it's also
possible to override the the rendering
method that we use in in the animation
class when you override the rendering
method on a servo and we can apply a
rendering method to an array of servos
Johnny Five has a servos class and you
can override the rendering math
and pass it through an inverse
kinematics solver that's what we're
seeing here it's responding in real time
to my movements my hand movements over
elite motion controller and it's solving
the angles for each of the legs in real
time and rendering that leg to the to
the proper position so that everything
stays in the right place you know
everything's in contact with the ground
and that's going to be an add-on module
for Johnny 5 called Tharp and it should
be out hopefully in a week or so so what
we're looking at here is that you
controlling the hexapod with your hands
that is me controlling the hexapod with
my hand with a leap motion controller
yes so funny story I remember when you
first sent me this video I was at home
and I was watching that and my sister
was behind me and she immediately asked
me that's CGI right she she oh she
seriously thought that someone had CGI'd
your hexapod in there because she's like
wait he's controlling it with his hand
I'm so scared right now and I said why
and she goes I could just imagine my new
robot overlord like with a guy just
standing on a balcony doing this and
robots to start attacking like one thing
I've learned is that we don't really
have much to fear because they fall down
and break a lot that's comforting did
you tell us a bit about inverse
kinematics and like what that does for
you so I'm totally unqualified to talk
about this but here goes kinematics is
the you know the art I guess of finding
the position of an end of the in
defector being the part of the robot
that interacts with the real world in my
case it's it's the feet of the robot a
lot of robots it's the hand the serial
manipulator kind of thing but it's the
the art of finding where forward
kinematics is the art of finding where
that in defector is in space given the
length of all your joints and the angle
I'm sorry the length of all your limbs
and then the angles of each of the
joints inverse kinematics is doing that
in Reverse you're giving a point in 3d
space and an origin point and you're
solving all the angles and links that
you need in order to get your foot where
it needs to be or you're into vector
where it needs to be
something to add is that for every joint
you add to the chain the calculation
becomes exponentially more complicated
so you can imagine a hexapod with 18
servos on board how so that's through
wait how many prim like I'm brain dead
right now three per leg yeah so that's
not trivial and as a reminder that's
JavaScript from the top down it's
totally JavaScript totally Johnny 5 but
actually will have to solve three servos
we like to solve one leg at a time but
still it made my head hurt yeah but now
everybody can do that well you know it
takes a lot less math because of the
animation library and this is also a
good segue into Johnny 5 has a new
website at Johnny vaio it is no longer
just a wiki page we have nice styling
this was developed at beaucoup not not
that the wiki page wasn't awesome this
is just awesome Merc so you can now look
at the API documentation the other thing
that I worked on yesterday is if you
used at the dash documentation
application the one that downloads all
the doctors for you and shows have been
offered i launched yesterday a doc set
for Johnny Five that is now in beta and
so soon i'm going to actually get back
tributed in the dash so that then no
more switching between browsers to like
write your court oh don't applaud me
applaud Donovan like that was that demo
is amazing um well so that is so our
next really cool topic yes sure uh just
real quick note about the website all
the content on the web site comes from
the Johnny Five the existing Johnny Five
wiki and the existing Johnny Five repos
example programs so if you edit the wiki
and like updated and improve it somehow
or whatever the next time i deploy the
site your changes just automatically are
included with that you guys open source
for the win right so if you also want to
write like new examples for for anything
you're like oh this is some cool use
case that I came up with you can
contribute that and it will be
automatically included in the website on
the next deployment
so your work for all to see and share
which is like my favorite part about the
website so sorry you can move on now and
if you're new to electronics this is one
of the things I'm super proud of with
Johnny photos documentation there are
Fritzing diagrams for just about every
example in every API page so if you've
never done electronics before and you
need to know how to wire something or
you're afraid you'll you know you don't
know how Johnny Five docks are very very
good about having Fritzing diagram for
just about every example we write so
that you can replicate our projects
fairly easily so our next really cool
topic / product is Bluetooth le is
getting really easy to get a hold of and
it's get we have a node module that
makes Bluetooth le a lot easier to use
is called noble the maintainer is
actually at the conference I don't know
if he's here at the taping but Sandeep
is here at the conference and yeah it's
really easy to use Bluetooth le and with
with node now and one of the really cool
products is a light blue beam which is
pretty cool $30 little it's tiny it's
it's a about actually about that big and
so it's got bluetooth LE on it's got its
own battery which is pretty neat and it
wirelessly synced and you can use node
with it via Louie you actually wrote the
Bluetooth the Johnny Five plug-in right
there's a bean dash I Oh Johnny Five
plugin so yeah if you put a specific
fremada sketch on the beam and connect
to it with will have your bean io
instance connect to that bean you're
doing Johnny Five on all the gpio is on
it and then the other way you can run
node is it does a sport no dread out of
the box which is a it's more of a
point-and-click programming language
that will allow you to do stuff with it
in the cloud so if you're dealing with
kids or people who are new to coding in
general no bread is also a really good
way to use that with it and Bluetooth
modules that we can attach make we mean
we can have more wireless Johnny Five
bots because you can do a serial port
over Bluetooth just like you do with
your USB cable and so if you have a
bluetooth module working either on your
arduino or with a microcontroller you
can have wireless no bots because and
yes so node blue and octo blue these
flow designers they actually reach down
into a way of some sort or no dread
itself and they can talk to to bluetooth
sideways across in the local area an
interesting thing also about this
awesomeness being all JavaScript that
that Rick wrote here with Johnny Five is
that we are able to do things like have
bean dash I Oh Johnny Five running on
say a tablet or a mobile phone because
we could just shim may be using Cordova
the same noble libraries and then you
can make a phone UI using Johnny Five
code talking to a light blue clean
connecting to GP I was controlling
something like this and it's all just
one set of JavaScript code from the
Johnny Five API standpoint we've been
really quiet so far so who likes
javascript in here audience that has
been super quiet like it all right there
we go there we go it's been really quiet
in here today um so I just have a
question though so can I do this today
you can do this today so there is it's
actually uh it was one of the things
that octuple would put together they
commissioned me to write a shim for
Cordova to do a to do a noble a noble
shim for Cordova right so you you can I
actually have an example on the ice dev
blog of how to do that so you can use a
beam from yeah from an Android and iOS
device whatever so that's a cool segue
we were talk about stuff we could you
today I want to use a node bot in my
browser can I do that say that funny you
ask yeah you can't so there's actually a
few projects going on so in the
education space you know Chromebooks are
you know 150 bucks really cheap tablets
you know are getting really cheap so
we'd like to do all this stuff because
it's written in javascript in in
browsers because you might not have the
ability to easily install node on one of
these things that's really just running
a browser so Pavel over there David
everybody involved with the Robotnik
application really cool this is browser
base it is blockley so using blocks to
create johnny five objects and run those
really awesome check that out on
Robotnik I believe it's on Pablo's repo
on github also so what I said was doing
we're taking approach of having Johnny
Five code specifically and we've got a
an IDE called chrome bots we haven't we
had an early version we demoed at robots
comp it was it was really just a proof
of concept Blaine over there has been
putting a ton of work into this and it's
actually becoming a good IDE now in a
browser for Johnny Five or for robotics
in general but with file management and
and everything and so keep an eye on
that because it's it's going to be
really good no so we're getting to the
point now where someone could pick up an
Arduino or a board and not even after
install node they could just open Chrome
your Firefox or a browser right some
JavaScript and controller robot
absolutely you're getting and which
really close you don't even need the
Arduino IDE or command line or do we
know anything because of work at Jacob
Rosenthal may or may not be in here um
that's done so that it actually will
write be from autosketch so yeah grab
Arduino plug it in and go I'll be great
for the Johnny Five website that way
like you wouldn't use Johnny Five with
node you wouldn't have to install the
Arduino IDE we can just put a button on
the website absolutely oh I see a pull
request got work to do I just want to
say about Robotnik last year at node
BOTS day which is july 25th this year so
right last year at node BOTS day my son
used Robotnik to build a pablo BOTS and
get it running all by himself he's just
he was 9 years old at the time no
scratch pretty well and the whole
interface is very much like scratch so
if you have kids it's a great tool so
that segues into our last two topics we
only have a couple of a couple minutes
left one is node BOTS day coming up in
July 25th so it was kind of a cool segue
um who here has been to a node BOTS day
before in their City or anywhere ok cool
this year I want all those hands to go
up node BOTS day is an amazing event its
worldwide so basically check your home
city if there's not an event run one
it's way easier than you think um so
well actually I got someone to do all
the work
for me in Austin so maybe I shouldn't
say that but it's so worth it um so
anyway uh you should definitely
participate in nodebots day
international event really great way
even if you just to barely started doing
no bots or are brand new to it a great
way to go sir I think most of us have
run a node wats the event at this table
most yeah yukino did it one and yes yeah
so the last topic i have is node bots
live the podcast so this has been cool
like doing it every six months on video
chris williams has been super great
about letting us use track be to record
a podcast which seemed really weird but
it worked out i actually want to take
this to a monthly podcast so i am
starting a patreon to get funding
because i do not have any podcast
equipment i do not have any editing
experience and so i'm going to try to
like get this going for y'all so check
the note box live twitter if you're
interested in helping out there will be
a patreon up soon and we have a couple
more oh yeah we have like two or three
more minutes so what out one more really
cool product that is coming out the
Esper e no pico is pretty cool if you
haven't seen it yet so if you never the
S Perino that's actually what's powering
this it's a controller that it doesn't
run note it runs like a modified version
of java script but it's very simply
writing it you don't really notice so
much of a difference from javascript and
he just released a new version that is
8080 bitty my tabs are tiny so i'm
having trouble playing there we go this
is about like like three quarters of
this long at about half an inch wide and
it fits in a USB socket and very
interesting project so any other cool
stuff that you all have thought of
before we run well i just want to give a
shout out to this team of developers a
year ago I was sitting in the audience
thinking I would like to contribute the
open source and I was nervous and scared
about doing it and I got involved with
Johnny Five and they have been
incredibly supportive and I have learned
so much so much more than I ever would
have just doing my work every day it's
maybe better at work it's maybe better a
better developer so thank you guys all
the field
I I'd like to add it Donovan is also
like my right-hand man now on the Johnny
Five project like code wise like I go to
him for advice about every single thing
like every major decision we have to
make I seek his advice and also David
Reza gay who is in the crowd as well
these two have become sort of like my I
don't know what you call it like I can't
run the project without them so it's
become less of an eye and definitely
much more of a wii and it continues to
become a bigger we which is exciting
over 75 raise your hand if you're a
contributor to johnny five how many
contributors do you have over 75 so up
let's give a round of applause for
community so we've got a few seconds
left if you get a little music like any
music is fine because we have to dance
it's a duration
you're welcome to dance with us we are
not thank you very much this has been
noteblock live and we will see you again
soon